today nearly 1 in
10 is food
insufficient that number has been rising
every year since
2014 and its forecast to become
considerably worse over the next two to
three decades this is especially true
for the poorer countries of Africa and
Asia where
the rise in demand is outpacing the rise
in our ability to supply I want to tell
you how the most important process on
the planet boosting that process
photosynthesis could alleviate this
problem how photosynthesis works is that
it plants remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere then they use sunlight energy
to convert that into our food release in
our oxygen at the same time
photosynthesis is the most studied of
all plant processes and from that
knowledge we realize that even our most
productive crops are only achieving
about 1 fifth of the potential
efficiency of that process as the most
studied of plant processes we realize
that the efficiency is low now if we
look at other genetic improvements of
plants these have typically involveed
one or two genes for example the
shortening of the stems of rice and
wheat allowing more of the plants
biomass to go into the grain that we
Harvest was at the core of the Green
Revolution that involved mutations in
just a few genes but
photosynthesis is a process of over 100
steps each of these facil facilitated by
a different protein and in turn coded
for by many genes so where do you
start well you could envisage this like
a car production line imagine you got a
th
workers where do you place them on your
line to get the most output similarly if
you consider the amount of protein in a
leaf how do you distribute that between
all these steps to get the maximum
efficiency if if you could work that out
then maybe you could make
progress however to do this
experimentally with all these
permutations may take decades so instead
we built a digital twin of the process
in which every one of these reactions
was described by a differential equation
producing A system that we could then
numerically integrate and optimize to
pick out where should we be making
changes so after 3 years of building
this system we were now ready to do our
numerical integration and it failed it
failed
miserably um fortunately another
scientist at our computer center heard
us talking about our problems and said
ah I had exactly the same problem with
my work on balancing Rocket
motors and here's how I solved it so he
looked at our problem and he said this
is more challenging than what I'm doing
and he worked with us and using his
methods we were now able to numerically
integrate our system and we could
optimize that and we could start to see
places where we might be able to improve
photosynthesis so that's just to tell
you that photosynthesis is rocket
science it's
harder
well well of course models can look very
attractive but when
you when you now have to go into a muddy
crop field to show that you can actually
do this it doesn't look quite so pretty
but despite these challenges we were
able to get together a team of experts
from Australia Britain China and the
United States to work together on this
and this is how we work we use this
digital twin to say well what is the
easiest change we might make that would
have a big
impact then we engineer that into a
crop if in the
greenhouse we can see that the
genetically
modified plant is yielding more than the
unmodified one then we have the acid
test of saying does this actually
provide a higher yield on our
experimental Farm now we've now made
three different changes to
photosynthesis each individually
increasing yield by over
20% and I just tell you
about a couple of these in a little more
detail um in one case the digital twin
said a protein we call
sbpa should be far more abundant in the
leaf than it is
so we put in extra copies of the genes
coding for that protein we made more of
it we got more photosynthesis we got a
high yield well this was a bit of a
mystery
because this protein is a tiny fraction
of the Leaf's total protein so why
hadn't Evolution already done this a
colleague pointed out to us that the
ancestors of our crops evolved in the
carbon dioxide
concentration this is about half what it
is to day aha so we reran the model at
this past CO2
concentration and we
found now that the model was saying well
we don't need any more of this protein
so then we got curious what about the
future in 2050 we're predicting a
considerably higher carbon carbon
dioxide concentration when we ran into
that higher concentration it said the
benefit of increasing this protein was
even greater
well we couldn't easily remove carbon
dioxide from the air around our crop but
we could add it and when we did this the
model prediction was proved that we did
indeed get an even bigger boost in yield
so this told us that Evolution has just
not had time to keep Pace With The
Changes we've made in crop environments
now another change we've made in crop
environments is to grow our crops that
ever incre increasing
densities this means that there's a lot
of shading within the crop so over the
course of a day leaves are going in and
out of shade due to clouds due to the
passage of the sun across the sky but
most importantly Shadows cast by other
leaves now for photosynthesis when a
leaf goes into the shade it's rather
like you coming out of the sunshine
going into the shade of a room and it
takes time for your eyes to adjust to
that change the same is true of
photosynthesis except it adjusts rather
more slowly than your eyes over the
course of a day this slow adjustment
costs productivity an estimated 20 to
40% so again using our digital twin and
also other information we identified
three proteins that we should upregulate
so we added extra copies of the genes
for those proteins got more of them the
leaves adapted faster to fluctuations in
light and in soybean on our farm we got
more than 20% increase in seed
yield so how do we now get from these
improvements to see
which will give greater yields where it
is most needed and I'll just give you
one ongoing
example um we've been working with TJ
Higgins a plant biotechnologist from
Australia who's been working in Nigeria
really for almost 20 years developing
insect resistant
cowp cowy it's probably not what you
think it is
um CPI is actually a nitrogen fixing
crop um related to soybean and it
produces like soybean a protein Rich
seed it is in fact the most important
vegetable protein Source in West Africa
and is often referred to as the poor
man's meat a problem with cowy is that a
pop boring insect can completely destroy
a family's entire
crop so
TJ's genetically modified cpy that is
insect resistant is very powerful and TJ
and his colleagues work with governments
in West Africa to put in place
regulatory Frameworks for genetically
modified crops and now this insect
resistant cowy is available to Farmers
in Nigeria where it's become very
popular
this year it was also released in in
Ghana so what we are now doing with TJ
is stacking out photosynthetic
improvements on top of his insect
resistance this is all
royaltyfree so that these farmers will
have access to seed which will produce a
crop which is insect resistant and
delivers a higher yield so I hope I've
shown to you
that by boosting
photosynthesis we
can relieve the risk of food
insufficiency for some of the most
vulnerable we can protect the
environment by preventing the need to go
onto yet more land to produce our food
and the possibility that we might even
be able to remove carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere
a 21st century Green Revolution one we
so urgently need thank
you